what I want to do with this video is
find the area of this region that I'm
shading in yellow and what might seem
challenging is is throughout this region
I have the same lower function or I
guess the lower boundary is y is equal
to x squared over 4 minus 1 but I have a
different upper boundary and the way
that we can tackle this is by dividing
this area into two sections and or
dividing this region into two regions
the region on the left and the region on
the right where for this first region
which I'll do I'll color even more in
yellow for this first region over that
entire interval in X and it looks like X
is going between zero and at one y
equals when X is equal to one this
function is equal to 1 when y when X is
equal to 1 this function is also equal
to 1 so this is the point 1 comma 1
that's where they intersect so for this
section this sub region right over here
y equals square root of x is the upper
function the entire time and then we can
have a we can set up a different we can
separately tackle figuring out the area
of this region from X is equal to 1 to X
is equal to 2 where y equals 2 minus X
is the upper function so let's do it so
let's first think about this first
region well that's going to be the
definite integral from X is equal to 0
to X is equal to 1 and our upper
function is square root of x so square
root of x and then we're going to from
that we want to subtract our lower
function square root of x minus x
squared over 4 minus 1 so minus x
squared over 4 minus 1 and then of
course we have our DX so this right over
here this is describing the area in
yellow and you could imagine it that
this this part right over here the
difference between these two functions
is essentially this height we do in a
different color is essentially this
height this height and then you multiply
it times DX you get a little rectangle
with width DX and then you do that for
each X each X you get a different
rectangle and then you sum them all up
and you take the limit as your change in
X or
which is zero so as you get ultra ultra
thin rectangles and you have an infinite
number of them and that's our that's our
definition or the riemann definition of
what a definite integral is and so this
is the area of the left region and by
the exact same logic we can figure out
the area of the right region the right
region and with then we could just sum
the two things together the right region
we're going from X is equal to 0 to X
sorry X is equal to 1 X is equal to 2 1
to 2 the upper function is to minus X 2
minus X and from that we're going to
subtract from that we're going to
subtract the lower function which is x
squared over 4 minus 1 x squared over 4
minus 1 and now we just have to evaluate
so let's first simplify this right over
here this is equal to the definite
integral from 0 to 1 of square root of x
minus x squared over 4 plus 1 DX I'm
going to write it all in one color now
plus plus the definite integral from 1
to 2 of 2 minus X minus x squared over 4
then subtracting a negative 1 is a
positive 3 we could a positive 1 we
could just add it to this 2 and so this
2 is just becomes a 3 I said 2 minus
negative 1 is 3 D X and now we just have
to take n the antiderivative and
evaluate it at 1 and 0 so the
antiderivative of this is well this is X
to the 1/2 increment it by 1 and
comment' the power by 1 you get X to the
three halves and then multiply by the
reciprocal of the new exponent so it's
2/3 X to the three halves minus the
antiderivative of x squared over four is
X to the third divided by 3/4 so divided
by 12 plus X that's the antiderivative
of one we're going to evaluate it at 1
and zero and then here the
antiderivative is going to be 3x minus x
squared over two minus X to the third
over 12
once again evaluated at or not once
again now we're going to evaluate at two
and one so over here you evaluate all
this stuff at one you get two thirds
minus 1/12 plus one and then from that
you subtract this evaluated at zero but
this is just all 0 so you get nothing so
this is what the yellow stuff simplified
to and then this purple stuff or this
magenta stuff or mo for whatever color
this is first you evaluate it at 2 you
get 6 minus let's see 2 squared over 2
is 2 minus 8 over 12 minus 8 over 12 and
then from that you're going to subtract
this evaluated at 1 so it's going to be
it's going to be 3 times 1 is 3 minus
1/2 minus 1 over 12 and now what we're
essentially left with is adding a bunch
of fractions so let's see if we can do
that it looks like 12 would be the most
obvious common denominator so here you
have 8 over 12 minus 1 over 12 plus 12
over 12 so this simplifies to assistance
is 19 over 12 the part that we have in
yellow then this business let me do it
in this color so 6 minus 2 this is just
going to be 4 so we can write this as 48
over 12 that's 4 minus 8 over 12 and
then we're going to have to subtract a 3
which is 36 over 12 36 over 12 then
we're going to add 1/2 which is just
plus 6 over 12 and then we're going to
add a 1 12 I'm going to add a 1 12 so
this is all going to simplify to
let's see 48 minus 8 is 40 minus 36 is 4
plus 6 is 10 plus 1 is 11 so this
becomes plus 11 over 12 let me make sure
I did that right 48 minus 8 is 40 minus
36 is 4 10 11 so that looks right and
then we're ready to take to add these to
19 plus 11 is equal to 30 over 12 or if
we want to simplify this a little bit we
can divide the numerator and the
denominator
by 6:00 this is equal to five halves or
two and a half and we're done we figured
out we figure it out the area of this
entire region it is two and a half